now just pause for a second don't write
anything I'm just going to explain the
question to you that's all the
information you need plus a sentence
he's the sentence right parabola a point
outside the problem sitting off
elsewhere you can graph them if you like
to prove to yourself - no on the crab
itself nor is it inside my question is
what are the equations of the tangents
from here to here right like if I went
in the opposite direction and I said
okay there's some point over here or you
can pick any point you like for any
point outside the parabola we'd be able
to draw one tangent to that closest side
and one tangent to the further side you
always be able to draw two just like
from a circle if you pick any point
outside the circle you'll be able to
draw a tangent to this side that's a bad
change I'm sorry and attention to that
side and you'll always be able to drop
truth my question to you simple question
is how would you find the equations of
those tangents from there to there okay
now let's pause for a second we have
this incredible tool here okay I'm going
to show you how to use it but I want you
to imagine Micah not that long ago that
you didn't know what that was and you
didn't have access to that as a tool you
can still answer this question can you
find the equations of the tens from here
to there but it's not easy I want you to
try it okay all right I'm gonna make a
start at some point if the light comes
on for you then feel free to ignore me
and just like how I get it okay and then
go ahead alright but otherwise let's
have shut up this I said we're trying to
find the tangents from here to here and
as you know okay now when you keep all
tangents you think goon gradients are in
bold usually what I want to find the
tangent or something you want
differentiate right so I would not blame
you if you would write this okay but
fairly rapidly as you start to work
things out you're like oh that ends up
not giving you anything
remember we're talking about you know
trying to put together the pieces of a
puzzle you get this and then you pick it
up and you're like wait this this
doesn't fit in anywhere okay it ends up
being not useful to this particular
problem because all
this point right you can only use this
if you know where on the table you're
already going to intersect but the whole
point is you don't know right you only
know about this point so this is where
the actions are really gonna be
happening now what is this what is this
life very good mm right I should have
written unheated and is actually you
know some number of course we usually
buy it for gradient and I don't know
what it is so therefore what this
represents this equation is every
possible line that goes through there
you recognize this right there's my
point gradient for okay now reason why
what point grandeur is because I know
that they'll the two tangents will be
two of these lines and I wanted to do is
pick the right gradient pick the right
gradient as aware if you like let's just
do this really messily okay y equals x
squared on 12 so we're looking at this
kind of faddish looking parabola like so
okay two negative one is gonna be
somewhere over here yes
okay now this what I've just written he
is every single line that passes through
that point of every grade so it's gonna
look like this okay that's every single
line isn't it okay
now exactly two of those lines and only
two you know something like maybe maybe
this one which is gonna intercept up
yeah and then maybe this one yeah
exactly two of them I just need to find
the gradients and then I'll have what in
which of these infinite green lines I
want okay sir to do that all I know
apart from this is the equation of the
problem and I want them to intersect so
how do you do things when you're trying
to solve with things intersect you make
them equal you solve simultaneously that
is why I made why why the subject over
here cuz then I can just chuck it in
right there right x squared on
twelve plus one excuse me that okay now
I hope you're satisfied that basically
all you need to do is video rithmetic
there and rearrangement and what's going
to plop out is this guy it's a quadratic
no surprises there right if you put it
in general form you'll get this okay so
that's after a bit of simplifying I mean
really all I did was I multiplied by 12
then I expanded and I got everything in
ax squared plus BX plus C okay now I do
in this thing I have this equation but
what am I gonna do in this right
we'll remember I'm looking for a value
of M well I'm looking for to actually
that are going to do something
particular for this parabola right now
this line told me again why did I write
this line again what what's that going
to find when I solve it it's gonna find
points of intersection right points of
intersection between this line and this
parabola but I don't just want you to
point some intersection I want this to
be tangent to math so how many points of
intersection should I expect one
it's a tangent right there'll be two
tangents that do this but I want this to
literally have one solution how do you
get only one solution on a discriminator
yeah once the discriminant is zero this
thing will only have one solution okay
so there's my beef in there so minus 12
and all squared there's B squared take
away for a see this
you can see I don't really need to write
the brackets in do i but I do it to make
it obvious that the whole thing is seen
okay now again look this is a quadratic
I should expect a quadratic why should I
expect a quadratic there's two tangents
with two ingredients right so I'm going
to solve for M and I'm going to get two
values out of this now I hope you'll
contend with the fact that this is just
you just have to sort of machine through
it and you're going to get two days for
M at the end they're going to be call
you what I got minus one over three or
one okay so here's my negative sort of
one and there's my positive one okay
what was the question again
yes find the equations of of those lines
which are tangents right so I've only
got half the way there I have their
gradients admittedly I've gone the
hardest part okay what I do with these
guys I'm gonna pop them back into yeah
this guy up here remember these are all
of those lines right oh in particular
values so you're going to pop them in
and you'll get some equations at the
other end what I got is this
okay all right so I skipped a lot of
working there right we talked through a
lot and at some points I said you know
from here to here you're gonna have to
do so simplifying it again you're gonna
have to do some simplifying
okay so what's written on the board is
dramatically shorter than what you've
actually done I mean this is this is my
working okay so there you go so it's
like a decent page okay
and also it's quite for intense did you
notice at certain points I had to ask
you who now what do we do right like you
have to pause and think what do I do
with this result and it wasn't always
clear